what is going on here is this a this is
the Asian spare rib
[Music]
my name is monkey Shawn miles hey what's
up I'm ruel belt hello my name is Louie
MacArthur my name is top rope Zeus and I
am here to destroy all barbecue dad's
alright so without giving away all my
secrets what goes into making a special
barbecue is the love you put in it you
know I think the biggest thing that goes
into it is just being honest about who
you making it for you know what you want
the reaction be
I'm in love with the grill I kiss it
this first time you got to make sure
you're connected with your one I also
have the sandals the brown grill sandals
the Jesus three thousands that all dads
wear with the healed out and I make sure
that always have a little bit of ash on
the back of my heel very important for
the season
mmm I just knew my Binion's gonna be so
begging
I forgot the ribs
[Music]
these beans are a don't look love you
let me they think my mmm-hmm now this
looks like somebody already took a bite
out of this one and it looked like he
just can't try to give us the whole rib
I'm a grown man
and this like a little kid read maybe
I'm a little bias on my beans right now
anybody play with their own things real
blue blue look like jerky beef jerky
because this is pink just telling me
that this is not done and it's tough we
don't even have to go there about me
that's not edible I mean I'm gonna try
it out but I don't know me alright I
think he went to try to put his foot in
it and kind of maybe just put an elbow
in
I don't even loves they cook these beans
you know he just could beans in the can
just blew me off that's what they did
okay another plate to the side nah yeah
let me check these beans out now I don't
know what he did with the meals they
taste like nothing these taste like apps
I don't even
I'm not even going back y'all can just
stick to the red bra on a scale of one
to ten I'm gonna give this one a six I
need some seasoning uh-huh oh you forgot
to say zero zero not gonna win you lose
I don't like it I'm sorry you can't even
eat that we went back to the drawing
board let it marinate like the sauce get
up in there at seven but he put the bean
with it
okay Danny's bugs oh you got a whole
damn dinosaur leg in this and he gave
yams and greens listen this definitely
looks like one of them real nice
cafeteria places that you take your
aren't after a good church service let
me show y'all this this is oh okay okay
okay I see you pops I see everything
that I want to eat but some baked beans
so even though he gave me a whole
Thanksgiving plate I'm just going judge
it just based off of what we going off
we don't see what stuff with just big
Jurassic Park real you can't let dad's
just be breaking all the rules even
though he didn't brought this big
Flintstones
rabbit in here let me say the grill got
to come off the bone fall off the bone
real rip I don't know if it's better
than mama it's pretty good damn I didn't
coach this bar because whoever here
please bring these ribs and you cousin
barbecue but I had to rate this ribbet
anything I give it a strong seven I
don't think you would get canceled at
the cookout I'll give this play tonight
cuz he got me thoroughly impressed it's
real just keep followed off in bold you
get a 5 out of 10 bro because the rib is
a plus your are no big Dean's the rib is
fire so you won't get a 5
yeah I smell that sweet and sour ain't
no barbecue what in the Panda Express is
going on here it's duck sauce on the
side of this this came with fried rice
and on fortune cookie what kind of sauce
is it it's just like some sort of
ketchup it's not good why people vegan
right here I feel like the other - we're
not following directions it's barbecue
rib just meat you know what I'm judging
it too much oh look this is it came with
a label I try the sauce from God to try
right I think I'm just gonna pass on
this one
don't think nothing about this look
right that's I wasn't trying things uh
it's kind of biting back a little bit as
it goes down my elk and the beans no
potato salad there is no spice to it
there is no seasoning it's onions but
big big onions he could have diced it a
little bit cuz we with if you had to
cook out and you talked to her you know
a little thing where idea you say hey
what's happening she's gonna be out of
it because of the onions
[Music]
I'm gonna give it away cuz he came again
it's a - I'm gonna tell you why man this
is not a real barbecue spare rib this
came with chopsticks and fried rice and
if you want to East Coast it's a big tea
that comes up in a plastic container
scale of one to ten I just give it a one
ribs and beans I thought we were all on
the same Accord here just gonna bring
beings up here did he hide the rib
hidden let me tell you something like
that show up to the cookout with a
hundred black hungry people with just
beans brother you won't see another
cookout I tell you that let me just set
up and try this dude because he got some
steam and we see what's going on is
being beans not seasoned people said you
got a season your beans mmm this guy I
think he tried to steal my recipe but he
left out the hot sauce he probably tried
to sprinkle some oregano on here either
oregano or he dropped a dime bag in this
thing considering that he didn't bring
me barbecue I don't know if he's grilled
the beans
let's give him a one cuz least the beans
were cooked and it has something else I
would've rather you showing up with the
ribs and not the bean don't show up with
your side chick sure but your main chick
so yeah it's overall score man I gotta
give him like a three and a half if you
forced me to score this based on the
fact that he had no grip I'm giving you
a zero my brother I love you but we got
to do better if we're gonna raise these
babies baby we gotta do better
[Music]
marathon continues happy Father's Day I
already know I'm the best out there
that's what I claim every day for love
and for soul in your food you've been to
[Music]
[Music]